well border officials in Texas say they
are seeing a sharp increase in migrant
apprehensions as many as 1000 a day to
handle the surge US Customs and Border
Protection officials have begun
releasing migrants from detention with a
notice to appear in court at a later
date now it's a policy that appears
similar to one the White House halted
last year homeland security secretary
Kirsten nielsen was at the border
yesterday in moravia diol asked her
about the apparent policy change is this
a reintroduction of catch-and-release
because that's what this new protocol
sounds like here in the valley yeah
there it's not a protocol and there's no
reintroduction of catch-and-release the
president has more times than I can
count made it clear it is not the policy
of the United States to catch and
release it's not but we were out of
detention space may not be policy but it
sure looks like it imitative ADL is at
the border in McAllen Texas pedrão that
was a good question yesterday good
morning well good morning you know the
Rio Grande Valley is the busiest sector
for Border Patrol the chief here tells
me that the migrants we are talking
about the ones that are being released
are predominantly women and children now
most of these are non violent family
cases where they are looking to seek
asylum we don't know exactly how crowded
these detention centers are that
secretary Neilson referred to because
the government won't allow us inside to
see but a number of local charities
along with the border providing shelter
say they are at capacity sometimes seen
up to 900 people a day most are
eventually bused north to other shelters
or to families that will be taking them
in now while secretary Neilson was very
adamant and saying this is not a
manufactured crisis an immigration
advocate we spoke to here on the border
says he believes the government has
actually been deliberately holding these
detainees to release them all at once
creating the perception of a crisis at
the time of her visit now after these
migrants our reliefs are supposed to go
before a federal court judge but one
woman says that she won't be able to see
a judge until July that is a full year
after she was apprehended and then
released David Mireya glad you're along
the border this morning thank you